[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Courtney
is in Los Angeles hi Courtney welcome to
the ramsy
show hi guys thanks for taking my call
sure what's
up uh my question is should we sell our
home to purchase one that's bigger and
has lower monthly payments um but my
husband would have to commute about two
hours to work no no
way he's going to hate that okay he's
going to hate you
well can I elaborate a little bit if I
may you can but I don't think it's
talking me into commuting two hours not
a chance I would do
that right no it wouldn't be an everyday
thing it would be so he's in law
enforcement so he has chunks of days
where he's working where he could be
staying with his mom and then on his
stretches of days off he would be
commuting up to us I don't like it I'm
just being honest with you you want a
part-time husband
yeah yeah I mean I'm kind of used to
solil Parenting with him being gone H if
you want to do it you do it you called
and ask if we would do it we were both
unanimous in a no what did he say when
you when you guys have talked about
suggest that he lives with his mother
instead of you so that you can get this
house what did he
say um I mean he's he's open to it he's
very cautious we've looked at the area
and at the housing and it you know
everything looks good but we're just
doing a lot of thinking a lot of praying
lot I think you're prioritizing the size
of the house and the housing situation
over the quality of your life of your
family and I think it's a bad choice I'd
agree with that I agree I mean that's
the way she framed it up a bigger house
in a lower payment but I lose control of
our family relationships they're all
over the place you scatterbrain the
whole place yeah that's not a a chance
not a chance I live 8 minutes from my
house and there's no one there but my
wife and my dog but I'm still still
going home in a few minutes wow that
would drown me bananas I couldn't do it
in 2 hours I can almost be in Knoxville
Tennessee and is it two is it two is it
two hours going and two hours coming
home that's four hour oh no way there
life is too short for all that yeah I
mean I understand in Los Angeles you're
going to have longer commutes than we
have in Nashville sure we have a better
quality of life than you do that's right
but but just the same 2 hours is not
it's not it's not sustainable in the in
a relation
context no for your kids your kids need
their dad more than that and and more
than they need their dad living with his
mom part-time so you can have this house
not a chance yeah I'm not doing it no no
no no no no no so it's
um here's the other thing um if if both
answers suck you have you don't have
enough options if the answer that that
toour commute sucks and staying where we
are is super expensive sucks there's
always a third you know what's the
what's another option's a fourth option
and a fifth option a sixth option uh
maybe we don't live in that area of
California at all that's right maybe he
takes a job in law enforcement in a
different place uh that is more
affordable that we can live in uh I mean
you know maybe you don't make enough to
live in that area that's a fact uh and
so then you're forced into other
decisions people have done that for
centuries oh yeah in the United States
of America yeah you causes people to
move to other areas uh all the time
there's always a migration in this
country and it a lot of it is driven by
economics mhm so um yeah that's a
possibility but yeah those aren't the
only two options in your life cuz both
the options you gave me suck you need
more options